une épidémie sévère meurtrière avec un
virus très contagieux touchant tout le
territoire national
les résultats les plus importants vous
le savez ce sont les données
hospitalières 202 767 établissements
aujourd'hui qui démontre l'impact
national du virus et de l'épidémie
toujours en cours vingt-deux mille sept
cent cinquante sept personnes sont
actuellement hospitalisés pour une
infection à kovy 10,9 dans les outre mer
on relève 158 hospitalisations dont 36
en réanimation 49 retour à domicile
on signale 94 cas à mayotte et un
premier dessin et donc trois décès en
martinique 5 en guadeloupe et un décès à
mayotte ce soit 5565 cas graves
nécessitent des soins lourds en
réanimation
vous savez ces formes graves touchent
des adultes 34 % des patients
hospitalisés en réanimation ont moins de
60 ans et 60 % ont entre 60 et 80 ans
soixante-huit personnes hospitalisées en
réanimation ont moins de 30 ans
cette situation est totalement inédite
dans l'histoire de la médecine française
aujourd'hui 4 158 patients de plus ont
été pris en charge par les services de
réanimation sur le territoire national
c'est ce nombre quotidien d'admission en
réanimation qui est le plus important à
surveiller pour prédire notre capacité à
prendre en charge les malades les plus
graves 3523 décès ont été observés en
milieu hospitalier depuis le 1er mars
neuf mille quatre cent quarante quatre
personnes sont sortis guéris de
l'hôpital depuis la même date c'est très
important c'est un nombre qui augmente
chaque jour
toutes les personnes malades en ville et
qui au bout de huit jours non plus de
symptômes pendant 48 heures
sont aussi guéris et elles sont très
nombreuses nous surveillons aussi la
situation en population par la
surveillance syndromique les services
d'accueil des urgences ont renseigné
4390 passage soit 21 5% de leurs
activités consacrées à des suspicions de
qu'ovide 38% d'hospitalisation après ses
passages aux urgences et 5% d'admission
directe en réanimation
les équipes de sos médecin rapporte 1718
intervention dans la journée d'hier
lundi contre 1953 pour la journée
précédente pour une suspicion de
qu'ovide soit 25 % de l'activité totale
enfin les laboratoires de ville ont
pratiqué 28 1846 tests dont 8660 se sont
avérés positifs soit 30% de positivité
le nombre total de cas confirmés par pcr
selon santé publique france s'élève dont
ce soir à 50 2128 il ya exactement trois
mois la chine notifié à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé l'existence dans la
région du hubei haouran de cas de
pneumonie d'origine inconnue le 7
janvier les autorités chinoises
signalait une soixantaine de victimes et
isoler un nouveau coronavirus un nouveau
virus humain
le sar skov 2 le ministère de la santé
en france
alertait les agences régionales de santé
dès le 10 janvier puis les
professionnels de santé hospitaliers et
en ville le 14 janvier par des messages
10 mars message d'alerté rapide
sanitaires et dgs urgents auxquels je
vous rappelle tous les professionnels de
santé peuvent s'abonner gratuitement le
23 janvier le chorus était activé le
centre opérationnel de réponse et de
régulation les urgences sanitaires et
sociales avant même la découverte des
premiers cas de covile 19 sur le
territoire le 27 janvier nous avons
activé notre centre de crise sanitaire
trois jours avant que le lord
l'organisation mondiale de la santé ne
déclare une urgence de santé
blitz de portée internationale et vous
savez que la france décidé dans le même
temps de rapatrier nos concitoyens de
one dès le lendemain par voie aérienne
pour une 14e strict sur le territoire le
14 février nous déplorions notre premier
décès de kovy de 19
le 23 nous passions un stade 1 puis le
28 au stade 2 le 29
un décret interdisait les rassemblements
de plus de cinq mille personnes en
milieu confiné le 3 mars l'ensemble des
masques sur le territoire national était
réquisitionnée et les prix des gels
hydroalcooliques plafonner le 6 mars
alors que 81 cas de contamination était
découvert en 24 heures dans la région de
mulhouse
nous demandions à l'ensemble des agences
régionales de santé de faire remonter
les cas de manière quotidienne
le 8 afin de limiter la propagation du
virus
l'interdiction des rassemblements de
plus de 1000 personnes était décrété
ainsi que la fermeture de l'ensemble des
établissements scolaires de l'oise et du
haut rhin le 10 mars s'étaient
l'installation du comité scientifique
permettant d'éclairer les décisions du
gouvernement le 11 mars alors que le
directeur général de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé dr tedros annonçait
une pandémie
le président de la république emmanuel
macron annonçait la fermeture de
l'ensemble des établissements scolaires
deux jours plus tard nous passions au
stade 3 épidémique est le premier
ministre edouard philippe annonçait la
fermeture des lieux recevant du public
le déclenchement du plan blanc sur toute
la france et donc la déprogrammation des
actes médicaux et chirurgicaux non
urgents afin de libérer un maximum de
ressources humaines et de ressources
logistiques
le 16 mars le président de la république
décret tel le confinement et vous savez
que depuis le 24 mars
nous avons un comité d analyse recherche
et expertise pour appuyer les décisions
du gouvernement
depuis le premier jour notre objectif a
toujours été d'offrir les meilleurs
soins à chaque patient et notamment les
patients les plus graves nécessitant une
réanimation c'est à dire des soins
continus des soins lourds une intubation
une ventilation mécanique une perfusion
des drogues très importante pour
maintenir le débit cardiaque pour aider
le fonctionnement rénale c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement complexe une prise
en charge en réanimation
cela nous a conduits au nom de la
solidarité nationale à opérer des
transferts de patients des régions
attention vers les régions les plus
épargnées par l'épidémie le 18 mars
grâce au soutien des armées nous avons
effectué le premier transfert de six
patients de réanimation par une
opération aérienne dit morphée les 21 23
et 27 mars trois autres opérations du
même type ont permis de transférer un
total de 18 patients depuis les centres
hospitaliers du grand est le 22 mars
était le tonnerre bâtiment de la marine
nationale qui transférait 12 patients
depuis la corse vers la région paca
le 26 mars le premier tgv médicalisé
évacués depuis la région grand est
vingt malades de réanimation vers les
pays de loire d'autres opérations du
même type ont été effectués le 29 mars
avec deux départs depuis le grand test
vers la nouvelle aquitaine pour un total
de 36 patients transférés du 27 au 30
mars grâce au transport héliporté dih
patients de la région grand est et 12
patients venant d'île de france ont
respectivement été transférés vers les
régions nouvelle aquitaine et centre val
de loire en bourgogne franche comté 42
patients ont été transférés vers la
région auvergne rhône-alpes par voie
terrestre et aérienne hier s'est
terminée une opération transférant tu
dis patients de cette même région
bourgogne franche comté vers la région
paca par voie aérienne
au nom de cette solidarité nationale et
au nom de la solidarité européenne
une nouvelle opération morphée a eu lieu
aujourd'hui six patients de la région
grand est ont ainsi été transférés chez
nos voisins allemands et vous savez que
l'allemagne nous amène aussi
voyez un avion militaire pour accueillir
des patients en allemagne
à l'heure où nous parlons d'autres
transferts transfrontaliers à
destination du luxembourg de la suisse
et de l'allemagne ont eu lieu ou sont en
cours pour 121 patients de la région
grand est
d'autres opérations sont prévues pour
soulager nos hôpitaux et nos équipes
soignantes
je peux d'ores et déjà vous annoncer le
départ dès demain de deux tgv médicalisé
depuis paris vers la région bretagne
pour 36 patients graves d'île de france
grâce à la mobilisation totale de
l'ensemble des moyens de l'état
nous comptabilisons aujourd'hui 288
patients lourds graves nécessitant des
soins complexes transférés vers des
régions - en tension ce nombre est amené
à progresser dans les jours et les
semaines qui viennent la région grand
est est en très forte tension sur son
système de santé la situation est aussi
difficile en ile de france
j'en appelle donc au volontariat des
professionnels de santé compétents en
réanimation
médecins infirmiers aides soignants et
les invite à se signaler dès maintenant
sur les plateformes du ministère des
solidarités de la santé pour soutenir
les équipes du grand test ou sur la
plateforme renfort tirek ovide point fr
pour soutenir les équipes d'île de
france
ils seront bien entendu mais c'est
important de le rappeler hébergés
gratuitement
je tiens à mettre toute la lumière sur
la mobilisation extraordinaire des
soignants qu'ils exercent dans le
secteur libéral hospitalier ou
médico-social leur travail sans répit
sur cette crise de l'ong est absolument
exemplaire
il est aussi important de souligner
l'union nationale dans cette crise et la
mise en place rapide et efficace des
coopérations entre les structures
publiques et privées les établissements
privés ont su modifier en profondeur
leurs activités pour répondre aux fortes
demandes sur l'ensemble du territoire
l'ensemble
des soignants du public comme du privé
mérite aujourd'hui plus que jamais toute
notre admiration et toute notre
reconnaissance
je vous remercie une question pour
hospimedia
les prestataires de services
externalisés qui interviennent à
l'hôpital et en établissements médico
sociaux craignent de ne plus pouvoir
assurer leurs missions pour le bio
network nettoyage pardon et la
restauration notamment
il demande de bénéficier de mesures
exceptionnelles pour accéder aux moyens
de protection est il prévu les inscrire
dans les secteurs prioritaires
oui alors c'est un travail que nous
faisons effectivement d' analyse fine
des personnels les plus les plus exposés
on l'a vu pour les services dell à
domicile on adapte à chaque fois notre
réponse comme vous le savez le ministre
l'a annoncé
nous avons commandé des quantités
considérables de masques de protection
nous avons aussi une production
nationale de masques de protection qui
augmente fortement
nous avons aussi des masques alternatif
qui permettent de se protéger et
d'éviter les projections donc tous est
cette arrivée désormais de commandes et
la production nationale et la
possibilité d'avoir accès à des nouveaux
masques des masques en tissu des masques
de la bave fait que aujourd'hui nous
allons pouvoir de plus en plus proposé
aux personnes exposées une protection
adaptée à leur exposition une question
pour france info
comment les remontées des ehpad vont
être calculé sachant qu'il n'y a pas de
dépistage automatique ni des cas ni des
décès alors il n'y a pas de dépistage
automatique ni des cadets des décès mais
il y à des responsables d'établissements
qui connaissent la conduite à tenir
lorsqu'il y a des cas suspects de covin
dans un foyer d'accueil de personnes
âgées et on peut tester des personnes
âgées
s'il ya une suspicion de co vite c'est
prévu depuis toujours dans la stratégie
de tests en france
il y a aussi parfois des décès et le
directeur d'établissement est appelée à
signaler tout décès suspects en
particulier s'il ya une épidémie en
cours au sein d'établissements pour que
ces remontées souhaite ensuite consolidé
par les agences régionales de santé et
que je puisse vous fournir dans les tout
prochains jours
la mortalité observée en est pas une
question pour france 2 envoyé spécial
le ministère de la santé at il prévenu
matignon le 30 janvier que les
municipales ne pourraient pas se tenir à
cause de la
mi à venir pas à ma connaissance de la
pm d'où viennent les cinq millions de
tests diagnostiques rapides que la
france a commandé quel pays quelle
producteurs alors c'est ce que je vous
disais sur les tests il y a plusieurs
types de tests il ne faut pas confondre
tous ces tests le ministre s'y est
engagé nous devons augmenter notre
capacité à faire des tests de recherche
virales sont les tests pcr sont des
tests qui passe par des laboratoires de
virologie deuxième type de tests
toujours pour chercher des le virus
présentant quelqu'un est malade
ce sont des tests dits non pcr qui
recherchent cette fois ci des fragments
du virus mais qui nécessite beaucoup
moins de technique
ça se peut se faire presque comme on dit
au lit du malade ce sont des tests
rapides qui peuvent permettre d'éviter
le passage par un laboratoire spécialisé
de virologie
enfin les tests sérologiques commencent
à arriver dans le monde entier puisque
là encore ce sont des tests qui
n'existait pas il faut donc s'assurer de
leur fiabilité leur sensibilité de leurs
spécificités de leur capacité à ne pas
avoir ni des faux négatifs ni des faux
positifs c'est important évidemment pour
les malades et donc ces tests se sont
produits à la fois par des instituts de
recherche et par des entreprises
industrielles et donc l'objectif de la
france est de disposer de test fiable le
plus vite possible et en plus grande
quantité possible une question pour rtl
les chiffres à venir sur les ehpad
prendront-ils en compte tous les décès
liés aux convives 19 survenus depuis le
début de l'épidémie
oui c'est ce qu'on demande aux ehpad
c'est ce qu'on demande d'ailleurs à tous
les établissements qui signale puisque
je vous donne le bilan chaque soir
depuis la mise en place de la
surveillance et en particulier depuis la
mise en place du test ne vous avez le
total du nombre de tests positifs en
france depuis la mise en place de la
surveillance hospitalière
je vous donne des chiffres de patients
actuellement hospitalisés de patients
actuellement en réanimation mais je vous
donne aussi le nombre total de personnes
qui sont sorties depuis le 1er mars le
nombre total de personnes qui sont
décédées depuis le 1er mars
donc nous aurons une vision globale et
je l'espère exhaustive de la situation
dans nos ehpad et puis enfin je vous
rappelle qu'il ya un dispositif en
france qui est très fiable c'est celui
de la surveillance de la mortalité
totale
qui remonte forcément à l'état civil en
mairie et donc l'insee et santé publique
france ont accès à cette mortalité
quasiment en temps réel et donc pourront
nous dire si nous observons une
surmortalité un excès de mortalité dans
certains départements dans certaines
régions ou aux niveaux national et nous
aurons ces données chaque semaine
portant sur la semaine précédente
une question pour usinenouvelle com en
l'état prévoit-il de réagir face aux
tensions et risque de pénurie de
produits injectables d'anésthésie et
envisagez vous des réquisitions alors
c'est une anticipation que nous avons
mis en place puisque vous l'avez vu ce
soir le nombre des patients nécessitant
des soins de réanimation augmente de
jour en jour donc nous avons libéré
beaucoup de lits de réanimation nous
avons quasiment doublé en quelques jours
notre capacité d'accueil en animation
mais comme je vous l'expliquais aussi
chaque soir la prise en charge en
réanimation c'est d'abord des hommes et
des femmes compétentes et il faut être
formé en réanimation
c'est ensuite un environnement technique
il faut un lit spécialisés il faut un
respirateur il faut de quoi surveiller
la fréquence cardiaque la fréquence
respiratoire qu'il faut des perfusions
il faut des machines parfois pour
soutenir l'activité cardiaque pour
soutenir l'activité rénale et il faut
des médicaments et donc c'est toute
cette prise en charge d'un patient
graves en réanimation qui a été anticipé
et cela implique des besoins importants
notamment en drogue anesthésique ou en
médicaments de réanimation c'est le cas
malheureusement dans l'ensemble des pays
du monde et c'est pourquoi nous aurons
nous sommes extrêmement attentifs à
toute tension sur ce sur ce marché il y
a beaucoup de solutions qui sont
cherchés notamment par l' agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament mais
aussi par l' agence européenne du
médicament
on peut trouver des solutions locales on
va dire des prêts entre établissements
de santé on peut trouver des solutions
nationales avec des des réquisitions
entre guillemets de stocks non utilisés
dans des régions où il ya moins de cas
donc là encore ce sont des ddd des
signes de solidarité nationale qui
s'exprime entre établissements et puis
nous mobilisons bien entendu les
industriels
médicaments pour nous assurer que
l'ensemble de leurs capacités de
production d'une part et que l'ensemble
de leur production est utilisable pour
nos malades
une question pour france 24 où en est on
des tests diagnostiques et à quel moment
pourra-t-on testé massivement les
français dans l'optique de la levée du
confinement
alors première étape évaluer l'impact
des confinement d'ici la fin de la
semaine comme je vous le dis le
l'indicateur principal sera l'évolution
du nombre d'admissions en milieu
hospitalier et tout particulièrement en
réanimation puisque c'est les patients
les plus lourds c'est là qu'il faut que
nous portions tous nos efforts pour être
capable d'accueillir ces patients graves
en réanimation dans les conditions
optimales
ensuite sur la sortie du confinement il
y aura de toute façon énormément de
questions à se poser
mais nous aurons besoin de deux types de
tests d'être toujours capable de
détecter des patients malades sur le
territoire national entrant sur le
territoire national ou l'apparition
éventuelle de cas groupés comme on en a
connu six si le virus se remet à
circuler et nous aurons aussi à répondre
à des questions importantes des
françaises et des français notamment
neige étaient infectées par ce virus
suis-je protéger et donc là c'est un
autre type de test c'est justement les
tests sérologiques qui permettent de
savoir si oui ou non on a des anticorps
et donc si oui ou non on est protégé
entre ce virus qui a circulé
parce qu'on a été malade ou parce qu'on
a présenté des symptômes bénins et qu'on
a besoin de savoir si l'on n'est
immunisé ou pas une question pour
pharmaceutique tous les soirs sont
annoncés les chiffres d'aegeri sortie de
l'hôpital comment a défini ce statut de
patients guéris sachant qu'il y en a qu
il ya des patients qui sortent en ayant
encore des symptômes non en pratique ça
c'est vraiment important de le dire les
patients ne sortent pas contagieux de
l'hôpital ce qu'ils ont encore parce que
souvent certains partent vers des
services de rééducation par exemple
c'est qu'ils sont sortis de l'hôpital et
qu'ils ont encore besoin de soins parce
que comme je vous le dis souvent on ne
rentre pas chez soi en sortant de
réanimation patron a besoin de reprendre
une activité cardiaque l'activité
respiratoire normal d'avoir des soutiens
infirmiers d'avoir des soutiens de
kinésithérapeute
de reprendre une fonction respiratoire
mais on ne laisse pas sortir de
l'hôpital des personnes qui sont
contagieuses canton quand les sorties se
sont confirmées à l'hôpital sont des
sorties de personnes guéries 10 à vis de
l'infection se sont pas forcément des
personnes qui n'ont plus aucun symptôme
parce qu'elles sont encore fragiles sur
le plan cardiaque ou respiratoire mais
c'est important de le préciser de même
que je le dis aussi tous les soirs mais
c'est vraiment important
la semaine dernière santé publique
france dont nous parlait de 42 mille
patients probable en ville et c'est
probablement un chiffre encore plus
important au cours de cette semaine qui
va nous être dévoilée par santé publique
france prochainement
ces dizaines de milliers de personnes
malades avec des symptômes bénins en
ville évolue et on le voit souvent dans
la presse bien et en quelques jours les
gens vont bien et disent je n'ai plus de
symptômes et donc quand on est à la
maison avec un peu de pierre avec une
toux sèche avec quelques symptômes et
qu'au bout de deux ou trois jours il n'y
a plus aucun symptôme on est guéri et
heureusement il ya des dizaines de
milliers de français qui ont cette
évolution favorable et qui rejoignent
danse est donc cette cohorte de
personnes guéries une question pour vl
médias alors que les hôpitaux publics en
ile-de-france sont proches de la
saturation comment les hôpitaux privés
sont associés à la prise en charge de
malades kovy 19 et leur engagement vous
semble-t-il suffisant oui absolument
c'est une très belle mobilisation de
l'ensemble des établissements privés
ils réagissent de 2,2 d'une double
façons soit ils ont la capacité
d'accueillir des patients covin ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas lorsqu'il ya
des cliniques chirurgicales par exemple
et donc si ils ont des capacités
d'accueillir ils le font et je peux vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui dans le grand est en
route france en bourgogne franche comté
en ile de france tous les établissements
privés sont mis à contribution pour
accueillir des patients que vides en
médecine en soins intensifs en soins
continus en réanimation
et puis il ya quelques établissements
privés qui n'ont pas la capacité
d'accueillir mais qui mettent à
disposition leur matériel de bloc
opératoire leur matériel données saisies
et leurs équipes et c'est pourquoi ce
soir j'ai lancé un appel aux soignants
qui se trouveraient sans activité ou qui
souhaitent qu'ils seraient prêts à être
volontaires pour renforcer les équipes
il y as en ile de france
il ya probablement aussi pau le grand
est des soignants encore disponibles ce
soit qui ont envie d'aider qui
souhaitent aider et donc s'ils ont des
compétences en réanimation s'il se pense
pouvoir aider les équipes de réanimation
du grand test ou de l'île de france il
faut qu'ils puissent se porter
volontaire dès ce soir
une question pour le huffington post
quel est le seuil au delà duquel le
nombre d'hospitalisations va poser des
problèmes d'engorgement dans les
hôpitaux
alors comme je voulais dit ce soir la
situation est très tendue en grand test
la situation est très compliquée aussi
en ile de france
ce sont des régions qui sont fort
heureusement bénéficiaires de l'aide
nationale puisque je vous ai cité tous
les transferts qui ont lieu depuis le
grand test vers d'autres régions depuis
la bourgogne vers d'autres régions et
puis en ile-de-france est un peu
particulier parce que c'est la région
capitale
il ya beaucoup de capacités de
réanimation et donc nous avons vraiment
là encore la possibilité du fait de la
présence de lits et de matériel
d'accueillir des soignants pour aider
c'est comme ça que l'on que l'on que
l'on préserve notre capacité d'accueil
optimales en réanimation
et puis sinon je le dis aussi nous
continuerons à transférer des patients
vers des régions moins touchées par
l'épidémie
une question de cnn le chu d'angers
annoncé aujourd'hui lancé une étude sur
l'hydro chloride roxy chloroquine sans
engagement financier de l'état
qu'en pensez vous et pourquoi n'ont ils
payent de financement de l'état
on a déjà dit à plusieurs reprises tous
les médecins qui ont souhaité mettre en
place des protocoles et là encore il ya
un cadre réglementaire en europe et en
france un protocole c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose d'abstrait c'est
simplement de proposer un patient une
recherche de lui expliquer quelle sera
cette recherche est de mettre en place
une comparaison entre un traitement
qu'on souhaite tester et un autre
souvent entre un traitement dont on ne
connaît pas l'efficacité et un placebo
et donc l'intérêt de ce protocole que
vous citez c'est qu'effectivement c'est
le traitement hydroxy chloroquine versus
placebo combat on ne sait pas ce qu'on
appelle un double aveugle on ne sait pas
ce que reçoit le traite le patient le
médecin ne le sait pas non plus et c'est
la seule façon d'aller rapide
acquérir des connaissances et de statuer
vite pour savoir si effectivement ce
traitement un intérêt ou n'en a pas et
c'est important évidemment pour les
françaises et les français que d'avoir
cette réponse rapidement
c'est un essai qui est d'ailleurs
multicentrique il ya beaucoup d'eux
d'hôpitaux qui souhaitent y participer
et tant mieux et on a toujours dit que
le gouvernement français soutenait les
protocoles de recherche qui ont un
objectif de production de connaissances
scientifiques et dans l'épidémie que
l'on connaît la production de
connaissances scientifiques est
indispensable et urgente une question
pour sciences et avenir le transfert de
patients d'une région à une autre est il
fiable sur le long terme
alors il est fiable sur la sécurité moi
je suis admiratif des équipes qui se
mobilisent parce que quand on voit un
tgv médicalisé on a l'impression que
c'est assez simple en fait c'est
particulièrement compliqué il faut
sélectionner des patients en
relativement stable si vous avez vu que
ce sont des patients de réanimation qui
bénéficie d'une assistance respiratoire
qui vont être transférés de leur chambre
vers une ambulance de réanimation de
l'ambulance de réanimation nous vers une
voiture de tgv qui vont être surveillés
pendant tout le trajet et qui ont à
chaque fois une la présence d'une équipe
complète de réanimation dans la voiture
du tgv donc c'est un processus très
lourd mais parfaitement fiable pour la
sécurité des patients ensuite vous
imaginez bien que ce type de transfert
est totalement inédit dans l'histoire
récente de la france et en temps de paix
et même en j'allais dire sans précédent
puisque même pendant les périodes de
conflit que la france a connu nous
n'avions pas de transferts de patients
dits réanimatoires nous avions des
grands blessés
mais à l'époque il n'y avait pas ce type
de prise en charge avec assistance
respiratoire une question pour ces news
demain 38 malade doit être transférée
par tgv vers la bretagne pouvez vous
nous en dire plus
avez vous plus de détails sur la
destination la gare non je n'ai pas les
destinations les gars et je pense que
c'est les français housse juste réalise
combien nous sommes devant une opération
totalement inédite avec des évacuations
de patients de l'île de france vers les
régions de l'ouest vers les régions du
une des régions du sud voit bien que il
ya un grade gradient nord-est sud-ouest
de cette épidémie on le veut on observe
bien depuis plusieurs jours les
principales régions touchées son grand
test au de france bourgogne
franche-comté ile-de-france d'autres
régions en moins de pression sur leur
système de soins et donc nous mettons en
place ce set mécanisme d'entrée dans les
deux sens parce qu'il faut aussi
rappeler que certes des patients sont
évacués mais aussi il ya des dizaines de
soignants qui montent au front qui vont
renforcer les équipes de vente s ils
vont renforcer les équipes de haut de
france qui vont renforcer les équipes
d'île de france avec du matériel nous
envoyons du matériel tous les jours et
donc il ya ce double sens de renforts et
d'évacuation une question pour auteurs
s'agissant de la montée en puissance des
tests de dépistage annoncé samedi
dernier 50 milles par jour fin avril
pouvez vous nous indiquer s'il s'agirait
de tests qui serait pratiqué par les
laboratoires de ville où adam des
infrastructures publiques ou les deux et
si tel devait être le cas avec l
répartition avec el maachi et combien
ces tests seraient réalisés alors là on
parle des tests pcr évidemment ça te
concerne aussi bien le public que le
privé d'ailleurs le pipe le privé je
voulais dit ce soir
pratique de plus en plus de tests est
tant mieux nous avons besoin des deux et
donc les machines que nous avons
acquises sont des machines automates
ils permettent de faire 2000 tests
chacune et l'idée est évidemment
importante ce soir et je la partage avec
vous c'est que l'ensemble du territoire
national disent bénéficier de ces tests
et l'idée définitivement que nous
puissions bénéficier tous ensemble tout
le territoire national
les autres maires évidemment sont
incluses pour accéder à ces plateformes
à haut débit pour pouvoir rapidement
augmenter notre capacité de tests pcr
c'est à dire notre capacité de tef de
patients malades suspects d'être
affectés par le virus du copinage une
question pour le généraliste un syndicat
d'anesthésistes vous interpellé sur le
cas de médecins retraités de la réserve
sanitaire mobiliser contre le coc vie 19
avez-vous pris des dispositions
particulières pour ces médecins plus
exposés du fait de leur âge et
allez-vous par ailleurs créer un
registre des soignants contaminée par le
strass cov 2 comme le réclament certains
indique à l'heure sur les médecins
retraités comme les soignants d'ailleurs
retraités nous savons que une attention
doit être portée au lien entre l'âge et
la gravité de la maladie donc nous
faisons attention à ce que les personnes
les plus âgées entre guillemets et qui
se porte volontaire ne soient pas les
plus exposés c'est notamment pour ça que
de nombreux médecins retraités ont
rejoint les centres 15 pour de la
régulation pour du conseil médical voir
pour de la téléconsultation ensuite sur
le sujet du registre je suis plus mal à
l'aise pour la raison suivante c'est que
d'abord il ya des professionnels de
santé qui ne souhaitent pas être
associés à cette démarche qui se
considèrent comme des patients comme les
autres et qui ne souhaite pas que l'on
tienne un décompte un peu macabre du
nombre d'infirmières d'aides-soignantes
ou de médecins qui sont affectés ce
d'autant que d'autres professionnels
pourrait dire qu'ils sont tout aussi
concernés par ce qu'il participe de la
chaîne de prise en charge
donc nous sommes évidemment très
attentifs à ce que l'ensemble des
professionnels du secours du transport à
personne de de l'ensemble de la chaîne
hospitalière parce qu'on voit bien aussi
qu'il ya des directeurs d'établissement
il ya des restes conservés administratif
donc tout le monde est concerné
notamment dans les régions les plus
touchées
et donc c'est un effort considérable de
protection de ceux de ce personnel de
santé
mais c'est aussi évidemment un constat
extrêmement triste que nombreuses et
nombreux sont les professionnels de
santé qui sont atteints par cette
affection une question pour la pm
combien de personnes sont sorties de
réanimation quelle part des patients en
réanimation cela représente-t-il
et quelle est la durée moyenne de séjour
constater quel est le parcours qu'ils
suivent après observation rééducation
alors ce que je vous expliquais sur la
réanimation c'est que chaque malade de
réanimation est différent et l'animateur
nous le disent tous les jours on a
énormément des changes avec eux certains
ont des profils strictement
respiratoires non juste ils ont juste
entre guillemets une détresse
respiratoire qui est prise en charge par
la ventilation mécanique
d'autres ont les tableaux beaucoup plus
sévère qui dépendent de leur âge qui
dépendent de leurs facteurs de risque
qui dépend de la réaction de l'organisme
à l'infection avec des défaillances dit
multi viscéral il ya beaucoup d'organes
qui dysfonctionnent ça peut être le
coeur ça peut être les reins et donc le
pronostic du patient est très différent
selon la gravité de son affection
initiale le suivi n'est pas le même un
patient qui respire beaucoup mieux tout
seul peut rapidement vous retournez en
médecine et ensuite chez lui un patient
qui a eu une défaillance multiviscérale
qui a des problèmes cardiaques associée
à des problèmes rénaux associés va être
beaucoup plus long à prendre en charge
la moyenne de séjour en réanimation et
environs de 15 jours ce qui est déjà une
réanimation lourdes est en sorti de
réanimation tous les parcours sont
possibles
le passage rapide en médecine le passage
au bloc opératoire parfois pour des
complications ou la prise en charge dans
un service dit de soins de suite de
rééducation de réadaptation cardiaque ou
respiratoire
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de patients et
c'est important sorte de réanimation et
c'est une victoire parce que chaque
décès est un désastre pour toute
l'équipe
c'est un drame pour toute l'équipe qui
s'est occupé du patient mais chaque
patient qui sort de réanimation est une
victoire
et heureusement ils sont nombreux
c'était la dernière occasion de
remercier